[Musique]
schalit voix 500 habitants faire face
cinéma pas de théâtre pas de
bibliothèque
pas de piscine le désert rural ce lieu
de rendez vous le café chez gaby moi
c'est dominique j'ai 18 ans je trouve à
une scierie dans deux mois je suis sans
succès j'essaie l'école d'agriculture
mon copain séjour je m'appelle j'ai 25
ans je travaille dans une ferme pour
couvrir et moi c'est odile j'ai 19 ans
en deuxième année de bts biochimie alors
moi si sa belle j'ai 16 ans et demi puis
je suis sûr lycéenne verges par attrapé
de comptabilité à la campagne des 18 ans
la priorité des priorités c'est le
permis de conduire indispensable pour ne
pas se sentir à l'étroit
non mais je ne me sens pas les droits
sur ce site est à l'étroit parce que
il n'y a pas grand-chose à faire enfin
il n'y a pas de prix mais de l'autre
côté pelt à l'espace plein de choses
autour de toi tu as des boîtes des 6es à
l'espace puis on a pas merci on n'a pas
les loisirs qu'on pourra voir en ville
mais moi je préfère est à la campagne
les guînes - dans la thur non c'est pas
comme si on était dans l'un des bureaux
être toute une journée à 6 pour bouger
on est tranquille on fait mon est libre
de faire comme la journée enfin dit oui
c'est d'épouser fois à nier est
différente de moi dans la mesure où
d'abord on n'a pas je suis le même
schéma scolaire
et puis wells qui l'intéressent et la
vie à la ferme tandis que moi même un
ayant vécu dans ce milieu là moi je me
suis pas vraiment attaché un ça te
dirait de rester là toute ta vie à
chaque fois que les copains tous à
cheval bon boulot je resterai là tu
préférerais plutôt que d'aller à la
ville bon faudrait peut-être qu'un peu
plus d'animation quand même se suivre à
yopougon chaussant les villages qui te
fait pas reçus par la reine du bal sur
les dimanches elle faute soit pour seule
commande a rencontré dominique moi je
connais depuis longtemps c'est
connaissent mes frangins stack opaque
un jour on sortait ensemble c'était chez
mon oncle chez gaby tous les jeunes se
retrouvent au café là bas au bruit des
pas sur toi chez les bovins les jeunes
semblent et boivent qu'on s'amuse comme
ça sort comme ça on les connaît
esquissée bière c'est le quotidien dans
l'unique café de chali voit la bande
d'isabelle dominique odile annie et
gilles se retrouve chez gaby le reste du
temps gilles travail
il est ouvrier agricole dans ce milieu
là mes parents étaient ouvriers
agricoles et de ce fait bon ça m'a plu
et puis j'ai continué dans la filière
jeu j'ai fait un bep pour faire ça enfin
j'avais un peu j'avais l'idée de
m'installer et en fait bon non ça c'est
pour réaliser parce que à l'heure
actuelle c'est il ya trop de frais que
c'est plus faisable pour ainsi dire à
questa envie de faire maintenant
pour l'instant je vais continuer comme
ça parce que moi l'avenir je joue pas
trop loin quoi parce que c'est bête de
loire trop long c'est ont vieilli trop
vite on sait où et pas trop loin pour
l'instant je reste comme ça tant que ça
va marcher comme ça
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
politique bon pour moi c'est nul
moi je m'étais as pas du tout bon chacun
ses opinions
j'y connais rien et maintenant plus je
m'y intéresse pas beaucoup
aussi je vous parle de jacques chirac
qu'est-ce que ça qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
inconnu au bataillon ces premiers
ministres il fait bien rire défaut moi
je connais pas assez pour toucher ses
terrasses de l'eau parfois françois
mitterrand ouais en fait ils passaient
mal que ça
peut mieux faire on en fait si mal que
ça
[Musique]
assez souvent le dimanche bon alors on
suit le match et puis après bon ben on
va boire un coup donc des fois les élus
match est bon c'est dans l'après midi et
ça commence à 3 heures et ça se termine
souvent le cas un tard le soir au café
voilà moi comment tu as envie de vivre
rapport à certains jeunes moi je pense
que l'amour existe encore je pense qu'il
faut croire à l'amour et que vous voyez
c'est vrai qu'il ya des jeunes moi qui
s'arrête à une déception amoureuse très
jeune et qui n'y croient pas vais enfin
moi je pense que l'amour existe encore
tu crois toi l'amour comment comment
avec un grand a
avec un grand a oui enfin moi je la vois
comme je le oui oui ça existe deux
façons ça existe
et comment tu le vois comment je vois
c'est difficile à dire façon déjà bien
sans enjeu c'est pas être complice tout
ça il ya plein de choses d'avoir peint
des trucs en commun fins comprendre tout
ça fausse et c'est difficile à expliquer
de façon c'est pas si ça doit exister
sans visage d'avoir des enfants avec
annie par exemple bah oui certainement
oui et pas de raison il en faut bah oui
c'est un but sait pas dans l'immédiat
dans l'immédiat mais plus tard il n'y a
pas de raison c'est ce ces chaudes des
enfants de façon c'est première chose
qui m'a demandé si je l'aimé les enfants
j'adore les enfants ont pu aussi ça les
gars on adore ça on n'aura pas une
ribambelle disons le maximum on aura de
serre alors deux enfants tu te sens déjà
une fois où tu te sens aux non pas du
tout moi femme non j'aime pas non vous
disons que je suis pas moi que je suis
plus une gamine je suis pas fan non plus
entre les deux j'ai fini mes études et
après mes études je m'en vais d'ici
ici c'est bien mais comme avec mon père
on s'entend pas pour une chose parce que
je suis
un gage et et puis mon père ne l'aiment
pas certainement déjà le fait que je
sois beaucoup plus de kani c'est
peut-être pour ça dès le départ il n'a
certainement pas voulu accepter qu'ils
vont peut-être que je suis pas ici d'une
famille qui a sa valeur quoi qu'ils
pensent ils pensent peut-être que enfin
moi je m'en fous je suis pour avec lui
j'ai connu est que je partirai plus vite
ce sera mieux pour moi et pour mon père
alors de quoi vous discuté dans tes
copines guano qu'au pad ça c'est le pôle
l'école c'est les week-ends ce qu'on
fait même cocasse en galère un peu comme
un attanquant ses thèmes chers à compte
aussi quoi et comment ça se passe avec
ton copain tu vois pas l'unique balle
vendredi soir jusqu'au dimanche
et comment ça va se passer plus tard
bon j'espère que face à pau j'espère que
ça va continuer ensemble tous les deux
et je crois que vous allez avoir une
maison vous allez vous installer
j'espère ça te fait peur le chômage qui
va arriver aux boys est ce qui te fait
pas bon pour voir ci dessous pour les
assurances en voiture
[Musique]
est-ce que je vous avais justement envie
de nous identifier à quelqu'un non non
on a chacun notre personnalité ce qui
sont maintenant comment on change
vous avez pas besoin de modèles oh ben
non odile elle a décidé de s'échapper
les tracteurs elle les aime mais de loin
elle a opté pour des études de biochimie
de la bande
elle est la seule à être allé au delà du
bac la seule à avoir décidé d'habiter en
ville la seule à vouloir quitter schalit
voix j'aimerais bien du chômage parce
que dans la passion que ça fait un peu
peur à tous les jeunes qui sont en ce
moment au lycée en train de faire des
études
qu'est ce que t'en penses quoi mais
c'est sur le chômage peut faire peur
dans la mesure où quand on en rentre
dans la vie active ont assez soit soit
tu es un boulot ou soit tu vas pointe à
l'anpe il faut bien le dire mais je
pense que il ya quand même une partie
des jeunes quand même qu'ils sont quand
même pas si pessimiste qu'on peut on
peut le penser et qui est qui envisage
quand même de trouver du travail après
avec un diplôme 1
après
[Musique]